SEE YOU TOMORROW FROM
WASHINGTON.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO HANNITY.
TONIGHT WE ARE BREAKING
BREAKING STORIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
HOUR HOUR POLLS HAVE CLOSE
NEW SEVERAL STATES.
WE WILL CALL RACES
THROUGHOUT THE HOUR AS A
RESULT VERY TIGHT RACE,
KENTUCKY GOVERNOR GOING ON
AS WE SPEAK.
FOLLOWING A HORRIFIC STORY
OUT OF NORTHERN MEXICO WHERE
EARLIER TODAY WELL AT LEAST
NINE AMERICANS WERE MURDERED
INCLUDING SIX CHILDREN
DURING APPARENT AMBUSH
MEXICAN CARTEL.
ALSO TONIGHT WHY DID ABC
COVER UP A MAJOR STORY
SURROUNDED CONVICTED
PEDOPHILE JEFFREY EPSTEIN,
BILL CLINTON AND PRINCE
ANDREW IN 2015?
A BOMBSHELL NEW VIDEO
UNCOVERED BY JAMES O'KEEFE
AND PROJECT VERITAS REVEALS
ONE REPORTER'S STRUGGLE TO
GET HER OWN NETWORK TO COVER
THIS INCONVENIENT TRUTH.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I HAVE HAD THE STORY FOR
THREE YEARS.
I HAVE HAD THIS INTERVIEW
WITH VIRGINIA ROBERTS.
WE WOULD NOT PUT TO BE THE
AIR.
FIRST OF ALL I WAS TOLD WHO
IS JEFFREY EPSTEIN.
NO ONE KNOWS WHO THAT IS.
THIS A STUPID STORY.
THE PALACE FOUND OUT WE HAD
HER WHOLE ALLEGATIONS ABOUT
PRINCE ANDREW AND THREATENED
US A MILLION DIFFERENT WAYS:
WE WERE SO AFRAID WE
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
INTERVIEW KATE WILL THAT
ALSO QUASHED THE STORY.
>> Tucker: WE HAVE WILL SHOW
YOU THE ENTIRE SHOCKING
DAMNING VIDEO COMING UP
MOMENTS AWAY.
FIRST BREAK JOHN SOLOMON, WE
NOW HAVE OUR HANDS ON YET
ANOTHER DOCUMENT SHOCKING
BETWEEN THE OBAMA STATE
DEPARTMENT, JOE BIDEN AND
HUNTER BIDEN'S VERY
LUCRATIVE POSITION WITH NO
EXPERIENCE AT ALL AT BURISMA
HOLDINGS IN UKRAINE.
NOW COMPLIMENTS OF SOLOMON
AND THE FREEDOM OF
INFORMATION ACT.
NEWLY RETAINED MEMOS OF
JUNE 2016 STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIALS ACTUALLY PREPPED
THE NEW U.S. AMBASSADOR TO
UKRAINE ON HOW TO HANDLE
QUESTIONS ABOUT BURISMA
HOLDINGS AND HE HAD THE
IMAGINE IF DONALD TRUMP DID
THAT AND IMAGINE THAT.
SAME AMBASSADOR TO U.K. WHO
RECENTLY APPARENTLY
TESTIFIED THAT I HAD SOME
ROLE IN THE ALLEGATIONS THAT
LED TO HER RESIGNATION.
IN REALITY DESPITE THE
OBSESSIVE FAKE NEWS
REPORTING BY THE MEDIA MOB I
DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
THIS WOMAN.
HER NAME WAS BARELY
MENTIONED BUT A FEW TIMES ON
THIS PROGRAM JUST IN
PASSING, BASICALLY.
AND TO THIS DAY I HAVEN'T
TALKED TO ANYONE FROM
UKRAINE THAT I KNEW WAS FROM
UKRAINE.
NOBODY, EVER.
I CERTAINLY WAS NOT LOBBYING
FOR HER REMOVAL.
THAT DID NOT STOP THE MASS
HYSTERIA FROM THE MOB OVER
YOURS TRULY.
I THINK THEY LIKE PUTTING MY
FACE ON TV BECAUSE THEN THEY
CAN TRICK VIEWERS THAT NEVER
WOULD WATCH THEM THINKING
IT'S FOX.
I DON'T KNOW.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IN THE NEW TRANSCRIPT OUT
TONIGHT THIS AMBASSADOR
DETAILS HOW SEAN HANNITY'S
ATTACK ON HER AND HIS
ALLEGED SUPPORT OF ACCESS TO
THE UKRAINE PLOT MADE IT TO
THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
>> THE SECRETARY OF STATE
SAYS THAT HE WILL CALL SEAN
HANNITY TO TRY TO FIND OUT
WHAT THE DEAL IS WITH THIS
WHISPER CAMPAIGN OF SLANDER
THAT IS BEING DIRECTED AT
HER TO GET HER REMOVED.
>> IN FACT AT ONE POINT IN
TIME SECRETARY POMPEO SAID
HE HAD TO CALL SEAN HANNITY
TO FIND OUT WHAT U.S.
FOREIGN POLICY WAS IN ONE
THESE TRANSCRIPTS.
THE LEVEL OF INSANITY AND
CRAZINESS AND CONVENIENT
CRAZINESS AND VONVENIENT
CRAZINESS AND VENVENIENT
CRAZINESS AND VENALNIENT
CRAZINESS AND VENALLAENT
CRAZINESS AND VENALLALITY IS
UNMATCHED.
>> THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED WITH
TASK IN THE SOVIET UNION IN
1974.
IT'S LIKE STATE MEDIA HAS
TURNED AGAINST YOU.
THE ONLY WAYS TO GET THE
GUYS IN STATE MEDIA TO BACK
OFF IS TO OFFER A SACRIFICE
TO THE GODS.
>> Sean: HE REALLY IS A DUMB
JACK ASS JUST FOR THE RECORD
BY THE WAY.
I NEVER TALKED TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE OR
ANYBODY ELSE FROM THE STATE
DEPARTMENT.
ALL OF WHAT YOU SAW OH,
SHOULDN'T BE SURPRISING.
LET'S SEE, A HOAX?
MORE FAKE NEWS, MORE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
NONE OF THAT HAPPENED.
BY THE WAY, MR. ZUCKER, I
HOPE YOUR STENOGRAPHER
HUMPTY DUMPTY IS TAKING
NOTES BACK TO SOLOMON'S BIG
BREAKING NEWS.
FOUND IN THE NEWLY UNCOVERED
DOCUMENTS AND BY THE WAY
THIS IS REAL NEWS.
IN 2016 A SAMPLE QUESTION
AND ANSWER SECTION ACTUALLY
IS PREPPING THIS AMBASSADOR
PERSON I DON'T KNOW MUCH
ABOUT.
HOW TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
DURING HER SENATE
CONFIRMATION HEARING.
ONE UNREDACTED SECTION
READS, QUOTE:  QUESTION:  DO
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENT ON
HUNTER BIDEN, THE VICE
PRESIDENT'S SON, SERVING ON
THE BOARD OF BURST MARKS A
MAJOR UKRAINIAN GAS COMPANY?
AND THEY SUGGEST THE ANSWER.
FOR QUESTIONS ON HUNTER
BIDEN'S ROLE ON BURISMA I
WOULD REFER TO YOU THE VICE
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN'S
OFFICE.
REMEMBER, BIDEN HAS BEEN
VEHEMENTLY DENYING EVER
TALKING TO HIS SON ABOUT HIS
UKRAINIAN BUSINESS DEALS BUT
IN JUNE OF 2016, YEP, SLEEPY
JOE CREEPY JOE, BIDEN WAS
THE OFFICIAL POINT PERSON
FOR ALL MATTERS RELATED TO
HUNTER BIDEN AND BURISMA
HOLDINGS.
SO, ANOTHER FLAT OUT LIE
WHICH EVEN CONTRADICTS HIS
OWN SON BY THE WAY WHO SAID
IN AN INTERVIEW IN THE NEW
YORKER, YEAH, WE DID TALK
ABOUT IT.
BY THE WAY, BIDEN SAID HE
AND HUNTER DID NOTHING
WRONG, NOTHING.
WE'LL CORRECT THIS IN A
SECOND.
BUT, TAKE A LOOK.
>> NO ONE HAS ESTABLISHED
THAT HE DID ANYTHING WRONG
OR THAT I HAVE DONE ANYTHING
WRONG.
PERIOD.
I CARRIED OUT THE POLICY OF
THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA, OUR ALLIES, AND THE
INTERNATIONAL MONETARY FUND,
THE EU, AND DEALING WITH THE
CORRUPT PROSECUTOR, PERIOD.
NUMBER ONE.
I DID NOT KNOW HE WAS ON THE
BOARD OF THAT COMPANY AND,
IN FACT, NO ONE SERVING ON
THE BOARD ILLEGAL TO BE ON
THE BOARD OR DID ANYTHING
WRONG.
>> IF HAD YOU KNOWN, WOULD
HAVE YOU SAID DON'T OR WOULD
YOU HAVE BELIEVED OR SAID IT
WAS WRONG.
>> NO, IT'S NOT WRONG.
HIS WORDS SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES HE WISHED HE HAD
REALIZED HOW KROHNS OF THE CROPP
REALIZED HOW KROHNS OF THE CROPE
REALIZED HOW KROHNS OF THE CROPS
REALIZED HOW KROHNS OF THE CROPO
REALIZED HOW KROHNS OF THE CROPF
REALIZED HOW KROHNS OF THE CROPT
REALIZED HOW KROHNS OF THE CROPE
PRESIDENT WOULD TRY TO PAINT
IT?
>> NOTHING WRONG, UKRAINE,
GAS, OIL, ENERGY, MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS.
NO, NOTHING WRONG.
NO EXPERIENCE.
CHINA, PRIVATE EQUITIES.
WE CAN SEE.
LOOKS LIKE JOE 33030 NEEDS
SOME HELP WITH PRETTY BASIC
FUNDAMENTAL FACTS.
MEDIA IS EXPOSED AS SO
CORRUPT.
SOMEONE MIGHT WANT TO REMIND
SLEEPY CREEPY CRAZY UNCLE
JOE THAT HIS SON HUNTER
WASN'T SELLING HIS
EXPERIENCE.
HE HAD ZERO EXPERIENCE IN
OIL, GAS, ENERGY, OR
UKRAINE.
NONE.
BUT HE DID HAVE A DIRECT
LINE TO HIS FATHER WHO WAS
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, THE SECOND
HIGHEST ELECTED MAN IN THE
UNITED STATES IN CHARGE OF,
YES, POLICY IN UKRAINE.
THE ONLY REASON HUNTER BIDEN
WAS GETTING PAID MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WITH ZERO EXPERIENCE
FOR HIS SO-CALLED SERVICES
THEY WANTED FAVOR FROM THE
BIDENS.
AS IT TURNS OUT, WE CAN
REPORT TONIGHT IT LOOKS LIKE
A PRETTY GOOD INVESTMENT FOR
BURISMA HOLDINGS.
WHY?
BECAUSE IN FEBRUARY 2016,
THREE WEEKS AFTER UKRAINIAN
AUTHORITIES CONDUCTED A
SEARCH WARRANT AT THE HOME
OF HUNTER BIDEN'S BOSS AS
BURISMA HOLDINGS, WELL
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE
COMPANY WAS ACTIVELY
COMMUNICATING WITH THE OBAMA
STATE DEPARTMENT.
ACCORDING TO ANOTHER NEWLY
UNEARTHED EMAIL OF JOHN
SOLOMON AND FREEDOM OF
INFORMATION REQUEST.
BURISMA LOBBYING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION TO END ALL
CORRUPTION ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST THE COMPANY.
ARGUING, QUOTE:  EVEN TWO
HIGH PROFILE U.S. CITIZENS
ARE AFFILIATED WITH THE
COMPANY.
INCLUDING HUNTER BIDEN AS A
BOARD MEMBER.
OH, THAT'S WHY THEY PAID
MR. ZERO EXPERIENCE, HUNTER
BIDEN, MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AND THEN ONE MONTH LATER,
YEP, THERE HE IS, JOE BIDEN,
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES IN A SHAKEDOWN QUID
PRO QUO JOE.
FIRE THAT PROSECUTOR IN SIX
HOURS, I WILL GIVE YOU A
BILLION DOLLARS.
YOU DON'T FIRE HIM, I WON'T
GIVE YOU A BILLION DOLLARS.
WHY ON EARTH WOULD A VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA CARE ABOUT
A PROSECUTOR IN UKRAINE?
THE ANSWER IS OBVIOUS.
HIS SON WAS BEING
INVESTIGATED.
EVEN THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
WARNED BIDEN HIS SON WAS
BEING INVESTIGATED BY THAT
PROSECUTOR.
BY THE WAY, DEMOCRATS, WE
FOUND YOUR QUID PRO QUO.
QUID PRO QUO JOE.
A SHAKEDOWN WITH TAXPAYER
DOLLARS.
AND BY THE WAY, IN SPITE OF
WHAT JOE BIDEN JUST SAID, A
SERIOUS POTENTIAL VIOLATION
OF MULTIPLE LAWS, OUR OWN
GREGG JARRETT LAID IT ALL
OUT.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN, 15 USC
78, IT IS ILLEGAL FOR A U.S.
PERSON TO COERCE OR
INFLUENCE THROUGH BRIBERY, A
BILLION DOLLARS, OR
EXTORTION, A FOREIGN NATION
INTO TAKING ACTION -- OH,
YEAH, THEY TOOK ACTION, FIRE
THE PROSECUTOR.
THAT MIGHT FINANCIALLY
BENEFIT THE PERSON, HIS
FAMILY, HUNTER, OR BUSINESS.
THAT'S JUST THE TIP OF THE
ICE BEG.
18 USC 201 C.
WHOEVER GIVES OFFERS A
BILLION DOLLARS OR PROMISES
ANYTHING OF VALUE TO A
PUBLIC OFFICIAL, TO
INFLUENCE AN OFFICIAL ACT --
FIRE THE PROSECUTOR -- IS
GUILTY OF BRIBERY.
WOW, THESE ARE REAL LAWS.
18 USC 201 B, GIVING,
OFFERING, PROMISING A
BILLION DOLLARS ANYTHING OF
VALUE TO A PUBLIC OFFICIAL
IN EXCHANGE FOR OFFICIAL ACT
ACT -- FIRE THE PROSECUTOR.
18 USC 1951, A THREAT TO A
FOREIGN OFFICIAL, IN ORDER
TO OBTAIN -- OH WE WON'T
GIVE YOU THE BILLION
DOLLARS -- IN ORDER TO
OBTAIN OFFICIAL BENEFIT,
AFFECTING INTERSTATE OR
FOREIGN COMMERCE COULD
CONSTITUTE EXTORTION.
BIDEN LEVERAGED 1 BILLION
U.S. TAX DOLLARS.
THAT'S RIGHT, DEMANDED A
FOREIGN PROSECUTOR GET
FIRED.
FIRE HIM.
YOU GET THE BILLION.
QUID, DO THIS SLOWLY FOR THE
MOB AND THE MEDIA, QUID PRO
QUO.
FIRE HIM, YOU GET A BILLION.
DON'T FIRE HIM, YOU DON'T
GET A BILLION.
AND SON OF A B, THEY FIRED
THE PROSECUTOR, WE NOW KNOW
BIDEN KNEW WAS INVESTIGATING
HIS OWN SON.
AT THE VERY SAME TIME THE
COMPANY WAS EVOKING HUNTER
BIDEN'S NAME ALL OVER THE
OBAMA STATE DEPARTMENT.
WHAT WERE THEY WANTING?
POLITICAL FAVORS, MAKE THESE
INVESTIGATIONS GO AWAY.
THIS IS HOW CORRUPTION, THE
SWAMP WORKS, ISN'T IT?
WHEN THEIR MEDIA MOB FRIENDS
LIE THEY SAY NO EVIDENCE OF
ANY WRONGDOING, THAT'S WHAT
THE MOB SAYS NO EVIDENCE OF
ANY WRONGDOING.
ONE OF THIS PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND DON JR.
THIS IS BUSINESS AS USUAL.
THIS IS OKAY.
NOTHING HERE.
NO EVIDENCE, A CONSPIRACY
THEORY?
FORGET THE LAW, FORGET THE
CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
FORGET THE BIDEN GOT RICH
OFF THE BACKS OF U.S.
TAXPAYERS AND DESPITE ALL
THESE DOCUMENTS, ALL THIS
EVIDENCE, ALL THIS STENCH
AND STINK IN THE SWAMP OF
CORRUPTION, ALL OVER
WASHINGTON, D.C., NOT A
SINGLE WHISTLEBLOWER CAME
FORWARD HERE.
NO OUTRAGE FROM THE MOB IN
THE MEDIA.
NO, THEY ARE TOO PIZZEY
MAKING
-KING
--ING
-- BG
-- BUSYMAKING UP EXCUSES.
BIDEN WAS TOTALLY PROTECTED
JUST LIKE HILLARY WAS
TOTALLY PROTECTED.
WHEN TRUMP UPHELD HIS SWORN
DUTY READ THE TRANSCRIPT,
ENFORCING THE LAW, ELECTION
INTERFERENCE AND ASKING THE
NEWLY ELECTED PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE TO COOPERATE WITH
THE INVESTIGATION INTO 2016
ELECTION INTERFERENCE, AND
ALSO LATER MENTIONING VICE
PRESIDENT BIDEN MISCONDUCT
AND THE COUNTRY, WELL THE
SWAMP ERUPTS.
THIS IS OUTRAGEOUS.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS IS
HAPPENING.
UNLIKE BIDEN THERE WAS NO
QUID PRO QUO WITH TRUMP.
NO CONFLICT OF INTEREST NO
CRIMES OF MISCONDUCT.
THEY GOT THE MONEY.
THEY DIDN'T DO ANYTHING.
READ THE TRANSCRIPT.
TOTALLY AVAILABLE ONLINE.
BY THE WAY, THE PRESIDENT
RELEASED THE ENTIRE THING.
WHAT OTHER PEOPLE SAY AND
FEEL ABOUT THE TRANSCRIPT.
WE ARE RELEASING SO AND SO
TRANSCRIPT.
THIS IS MEANINGLESS.
O MY GOD SOMEBODY SAID THEY
THINK IT'S BAD.
MEANINGLESS.
READ THE TRANSCRIPT.
THE PRESIDENT WAS FAITHFULLY
EXECUTING THE LAWS OF THE
LAND.
I THOUGHT LIBERALS CARED
ABOUT FOREIGN ELECTION
INTERFERENCE.
LOOK AT THIS CORRUPTION.
THEY WANTED A FAVOR FROM THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION STATE
DEPARTMENT.
EXISTED ON SO MANY LEVELS.
RELEASING TRANSCRIPTS OF THE
NEW NORM, REPUBLICANS
TONIGHT NEED TO BEGIN
DEMANDING THAT THE RELEASE
OF ALL TRANSCRIPTS OF VICE
PRESIDENT BIDEN WITH ANY
UKRAINIAN OFFICIAL IN THIS
PERIOD OF TIME, AS A MATTER
OF FACT, DO IT FOR THE WHOLE
TIME HE WAS VICE PRESIDENT.
RELEASE ALL THE TRANSCRIPTS
OF THE VICE PRESIDENT AND
THEN BIDEN AND CHINA AND ANY
OTHER COUNTRY PAYING HIS
ZERO EXPERIENCE SON A
FORTUNE, MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
NO OTHER AMERICANS GETTING
THAT DEAL.
LET'S RELEASE WHILE WE ARE
AT IT OF ALL TRANSCRIPTS OF
THEN PRESIDENT OBAMA WITH
VLAD PUTIN AND OTHER RUSSIAN
LEADER AFTER HE HAD MORE
FLEXIBILITY AFTER HIS
REELECTIONS.
WHILE WE ARE AT IT LET'S
RELEASE ANY AND ALL
TRANSCRIPTS OF THEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA WITH ANY OF
THE LEADERS WITH IRAN.
AND THE DISCUSSIONS THAT LED
UP TO THE STUPIDITY AND THE
IDIOCY OF GIVING THE MULLAHS
IN IRAN DEATH CHANT TO
ISRAEL A BILLION AND OTHER
CASH AND CURRENCY.
WHY WOULD YOU EVER DO THAT?
PRODUCTIONS NEED TO
REODUCTIONS NEED TO
REPUUCTIONS NEED TO
REPUBLTIONS NEED TO
REPUBLICONS NEED TO
REPUBLICANS NEED TO KNOW.
THE MEDIA NEEDS TO ASK JOE
AND OBAMA, HEY, DID YOU GUYS
GIVE US PERMISSION TO LOOK
AT THOSE TRANSCRIPTS?
I HAVE A FUNNY FEELING THEY
ARE NOT GOING TO WANT THOSE
TRANSCRIPTS RELEASED.
BY THE WAY, REPUBLICANS MUST
DEMAND SUBPOENAS WHILE THEY
ARE AT IT FOR VERY IMPORTANT
WITNESSES.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
THE NON-WHISTLEBLOWER
WHISTLEBLOWER.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE SEAR SAY
THE BFF OF THE COMPROMISE
COWARD AND -- YEAH.
THE CONGENITAL LIAR, ADAM
SCHIFF.
AND APPARENTLY HIS STAFF.
ALSO APPARENTLY FRIENDS YOU
HAVE BIDEN.
HE WASN'T ON THE CALL.
HIS INFORMATION WAS HEARSAY,
THIRD HAND MATERIAL.
REPUBLICANS MUST DEMAND THIS
WHISTLEBLOWER GO UNDER OATH.
WHAT WAS THE CONTACT WITH
SCHIFF'S OFFICE?
WHAT WAS THE RELATIONSHIP
WITH BIDEN?
WHO WAS THE PERSON WHO GAVE
YOU THIS THIRD HAND
INFORMATION?
LET'S BE CLEAR, THE
WHISTLEBLOWER STATUTE DOES
NOT GUARANTEE ANONYMITY.
DOES PROTECT AGAINST
RETRIBUTION AND RETALIATION.
MUST ALSO DEMAND THAT HUNTER
AND JOE BIDEN THAT THEY BE
PUT UNDER OATH, THAT THEY BE
SUBPOENAED.
LET'S NOT FORGET THE CORRUPT
COMPROMISED CONGENITAL LIAR
ADAM SCHIFF.
HE IS NOW A FACT WITNESS OF
THIS CASE.
LET'S PUT HIM UNDER OATH.
SCHIFF, IN FACT, HIS OFFICE,
WHAT ADVICE DID THEY OFFER
THE NON-WHISTLEBLOWER,
WHISTLEBLOWER FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING?
HE CAN'T BRING THE
WHISTLEBLOWER IN BECAUSE THE
WHISTLEBLOWER WILL BE ASKED
QUESTIONS ABOUT HIM.
THIS IS A SET-UP.
IT'S ALL BEEN CONJURED AGAIN
BY DEEP STATE UNELECTED
BREWER DEMOCRATS THAT ARE
JUST OBSESSED WITH
IMPEACHING TRUMP BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T BEAT HIM.
CARRYING OUT THE MOST
CORRUPT PERSON IN WASHINGTON
THIS WHOLE THING IS BEING
CARRIED OUT BY THE BIGGEST
CONGENITAL LIAR.